there is evidence to criminally charge
the failed former president Donald Trump
says Adam Schiff member of the January
6th committee we have video of Adam
Schiff explaining I've seen the evidence
there is evidence that Donald Trump
committed criminal offenses in his
effort to overturn the 2020 election now
Adam Schiff has previously said things
like we have the evidence that will put
Don Jr in prison or at least get him
charged and it appears as though he was
wrong about that so Adam Schiff is no
Panacea but we are within hours right
now of the January 6 committee making
criminal referrals we don't yet know
who's going to be on that list and you
have Adam Schiff saying the following
let's take a listen and then discuss
what we'll discuss well what could be
those charges uh I think that the
evidence is there that Donald Trump
committed uh criminal offenses in
connection with his efforts to overturn
the election and viewing it as a former
prosecutor I think there's sufficient
evidence to to charge the president wow
action now well I don't know what the
justice department has I do know what's
in the public record the evidence seems
pretty plain to me but I would want to
see the full body of evidence if I were
in the prosecutor's shoes to make a
decision but uh you know this is someone
who uh in multiple ways tried to
pressure State officials to find votes
that didn't exist this is someone who
tried to interfere with a joint session
uh even inciting a mob to attack the
capital true
um if that's not criminal then uh
now I know what it is so let's take this
seriously and think it through let's not
speak in general terms about this
according to the investigation by the
January 6 committee there's evidence
that Trump committed crimes that's what
Adam Schiff is telling us and we've
heard it from others the committee did
find that Trump made false statements
about the results of the 2020 election
insofar as he claimed that he won even
though he lost
and then he used those false statements
to encourage his followers to challenge
the results
in so doing he encouraged the violent
attack on the U.S Capitol on January 6
2021 which about a million of us on our
stream watched live on that day the
evidence against Trump includes his own
words which the committee has looked at
extensively the actions of those who
participated in the attacks and their
claims that they were there because
Trump told him to go
Trump made repeated claims that the
election was stolen from him he made
false claims that it was stolen in
particular ways none of which were found
to be uh have any Merit he urged his
supporters to quote never give up to
never concede to fight like hell to
March to the capital to show support for
him in addition to Trump's public words
we have evidence of the planning and the
coordination and the behind the scenes
of this plan that was drafted up for
Trump
four mic pens to again at this point we
don't even really understand what he was
supposed to do quote send it back to the
states or recognize alternate electors
all things that he couldn't do
but there was planning there was legal
work that went into that and we have
other individuals that were involved who
were caught on video discussing the plan
discussing how to disrupt the election
results and some were even seeing
wearing tactical gear and and some of
them even had weapons so this was all a
major plan
if Donald Trump were to be charged in
connection with the attack
from what happened on January 6th the
possible consequences could include
fines imprisonment or both and we'll
talk about the prison piece a little
later Glenn kirschner had an interesting
comment about that's all hypothetical
but what would the specific charges be
Trump could face potentially
incitement to Riot
conspiracy obstruction of justice among
other crimes each carries its own
potential penalties and the penalties
depend on the severity of the offense
and other factors including what he
would ultimately be convicted of in this
completely hypothetical scenario we're
talking about now of course just because
you're charged doesn't mean you're going
to be found guilty in the interview with
Adam Schiff Jake Tapper asks a good
question which is okay you might have
the evidence for an indictment but you
have the evidence for a conviction those
are two dramatically different questions
and at the end of the the entire thing
is a question I've asked before
can you find a jury in the United States
that will fairly adjudicate Donald Trump
and what I mean by that is is there
really anyone in the U.S who would say
I am open-minded enough about Trump
that whatever preconceived notions I
have about him and what he did I will
rule based only on the evidence
presented in this trial I don't know
that I could do that I don't know that I
could do that because it would be very
difficult for me to completely put aside
everything that over the last five years
and in the couple of years since the
riots uh in the year plus since the riot
almost two years since the riots I have
learned about Donald Trump so so there
is a real question can Trump get an
actual Fair jury trial in the U.S
that'll be a conversation we have a
little bit later when you're looking for
a good documentary to watch you scroll
through Netflix and Hulu for a while
there aren't that many you realize
you've seen the good ones what if I told
you there's a streaming platform
exclusively for documentaries with the
best selection where you won't run out
of top quality documentaries that is
curiosity stream with a massive catalog
of the newest and best documentaries
classic titles from years ago exclusive
content you can't find anywhere else I
just watched Pompeii disaster Street I
visited Pompeii in Italy before I wish I
had seen the documentary before visiting
because it was made very very clear I
missed a lot when I actually went to
Pompeii you can watch curiositystream on
all of your devices they're always
adding new titles politics philosophy
True Crime nature they have everything
and my audience gets curiosity stream
for under two bucks a month when you go
to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below